muy bien aquí yo tengo dos interruptores
de un polo y doble tiro con palanca y
los colocaremos sobre nuestro robot
entonces pegaremos los interruptores en
los extremos de nuestro robot de esta
forma y bueno hay que asegurarnos que a
la hora de pegar los queden un poco
fuera del robot de esta forma y en un
ángulo aproximado de 45 grados entonces
para hacer esto voy a tomar el silicón
caliente pongo un poco aquí pongo un
poco acá y ahora vamos a tomar los
interruptores y los pegamos en la forma
que les comenté entonces tomamos así los
interruptores los colocamos pero ten
cuidado de que el silicón no interfiera
con la palanca
y ahora agregamos las dos baterías y
esto lo hacemos solo para agregar un
poco de peso a la caja de baterías y así
se mantenga un poco más estable ahora
cuando hagas eso ten cuidado porque tú
no quieres que estos dos cables se
toquen porque bueno si se tocan van a
crear un corto la batería y bueno se va
a derretir el estuche y todo entonces
bueno tú no quieres que eso pase pero lo
que sí queremos hacer es vamos a tomar
otro cable este es un cable de calibre
22 con núcleo sólido ahora vamos a pelar
un poco de este extremo aproximadamente
tres cuartos de pulgada entonces tomamos
el pelador de cable y le pelamos un
extremo y ya que tenemos esto vamos a
pasar el cable a través de estos
agujeros observa que los interruptores
tienen unos agujeros en las conexiones
vamos a pasar el cable por ahí y después
vamos a conectarlo con este cable y eso
nos permitirá conectar dos lados de
nuestros interruptores de un polo y
doble tiro y también nos dará un cable
extra
que vamos a poder usar para encender
nuestras luces led entonces tomamos
nuestras pinzas de punta y con ellas
vamos a intentar doblar este cable
vamos a intentar doblar este cable para
poder atravesarlo por estos agujeros
y como te digo es algo truculento pero
bueno lo que tú quieres lograr es hacer
que el cable pase por los dos agujeros
de las conexiones de los interruptores
porque bueno esto te dará una mejor
conexión a la hora de soldar lo
y bueno más que difícil lo que pasa es
que tarda un poco de tiempo trabajar en
esto y de hecho creo que despegue el
interruptor 7 -hechos y lo hice entonces
bueno para arreglar esto es bastante
sencillo simplemente voy a quitar el
pegamento
que ya seco este pegamento se lo quitó y
si te pasa a ti asegúrate de quitarle
todo el pegamento pero es bueno esto que
nos ha pasado porque nos permitirá de
una manera más sencilla conectar los
interruptores entonces lo que haré a
continuación es poner un poco de silicón
caliente en la esquina del robot
y bueno le voy a pegar nuevamente el
interruptor así que hago eso ponemos un
poco de pegamento aquí
y después colocamos el interruptor ten
cuidado recuerda que es pegamento
caliente no quiere es poner pegamento
caliente en sus dedos entonces bueno se
puede quemar y no no es nada divertido
así que ahí quedó ya ahí está ya tenemos
el interruptor en su lugar
pero antes de seguir veamos si podemos
maniobrar un poco más esto de pasar el
cable por los agujeros de los
interruptores solamente quiero quiero
que quede un poco mejor esto
y ahora qué vamos a hacer vamos a tomar
el cable rojo
le vamos a pegar el pedazo del núcleo
sólido del cable que pelamos
anteriormente entonces bueno ahora aquí
a este cable rojo le quitamos le
quitamos un pedazo y después tomamos el
pelador de cables y le quitamos el
exceso aquí entonces ya que tenemos aquí
al cable rojo que lo acabamos de pelar a
éste lo vamos a torcer y lo vamos a
entrelazar con el cable del núcleo
sólido
a estos dos nos vamos a entrelazar de
esta manera entonces los entrelazamos y
ahí están así que ya tenemos una buena
conexión aquí y ahora qué es lo que
sigue ahora vamos a soldar ya podemos
soldar así que hagámoslo vamos a tomar
el cautín tomamos nuestro cautín y
recuerda que primero limpiamos la punta
del cautín entonces pongo un poco de
soldadura en la punta del cautín y
después se lo quitamos quitamos el
exceso a la punta del kaupthing
entonces ahí está ahora vamos a tomar el
cautín y vamos a colocarlo sobre el
cable para que el cable se caliente y la
soldadura fluya sobre el cable no es
necesario que la soldadura toque al
cautín con que el cautín toque al cable
lo calentará tanto que la soldadura
caerá directamente sobre el cable
debe haber soldadura en todo lo que
quiere soldar así ya quedó bien pero aún
aquí hay un lugar que falta para tener
una buena conexión
muy bien ahí está
ahora qué es lo que sigue ahora
necesitamos conectar nuestro siguiente
cable el siguiente cable es nuestro
cable blanco así que vamos a conectar
nuestro cable blanco entonces bueno para
esto
vamos a tomar el cable blanco
aquí ya lo tenemos y vamos a quitarle un
pedazo del aislamiento vamos a quitarle
aproximadamente esta cantidad entonces
tomamos el pelador de cables y se lo
quitamos entonces bueno ahí ya tenemos
el cable blanco lo pelamos le quitamos
el aislamiento de un extremo y vamos a
hacer vamos a hacer que atraviese este
cable blanco
los agujeros de enmedio de las
conexiones de nuestros interruptores
hagamos que el cable que el cable blanco
atraviese los agujeros de nuestros
interruptores
no necesitamos el aislamiento aquí en la
parte del medio siempre y cuando el
cable blanco no toque al cable rojo
si no se tocan si el cable rojo y el
cable blanco no se tocan entonces todo
está perfectamente bien
entonces a estos dos a estos dos cables
vamos a mantenerlos muy bien separados
al cable blanco y al cable rojo
mantengamos los separados entonces hago
esta curvatura en el cable blanco para
que bueno asegurar que queden que jamás
se peguen ellos dos y vamos a tomar el
cable negro vamos a cortarlo íbamos a
quitar aquí el exceso de aislamiento del
cable negro
y vamos a hacer lo mismo que hicimos
anteriormente vamos a tomar el cable
rojo y al cable en negro y vamos a
trenzar los
y ya que hicimos esto podemos tomar el
cautín y vamos a soldar todas las partes
entonces soldamos todas las partes
primero vamos a soldar el cable y el
interruptor
ahí quedó
segundo vamos a soldar el cable negro
con el cable blanco
ahí está
muy bien y finalmente necesitamos soldar
el cable blanco con el otro lado es
decir el otro lado de del interruptor
vamos a soldar estas partes
muy bien
ahí está el cable blanco con el
interruptor y listo ya tenemos todas las
conexiones ya hemos soldado todo lo que
teníamos que soldar y como puedes
observar aquí
sobra un poco de cable entonces
simplemente córtalo no no pasa nada hay
que mantener esto lo más sencillo
posible
también puedes con las pinzas quitar o
mover lo que te esté estorbando pero
recuerda que puedes hacer lo que aquí tú
quieras acomodar esto pero no no
permitas que el cable negro y el cable
rojo se toquen también observa que todas
las conexiones tengan soldadura en todas
las partes por ejemplo aquí a mí me hizo
falta en este punto entonces le pongo un
poco más de soldadura
entonces bueno también las palancas
siguen funcionando perfecto todo todo va
en orden